- [Kelly] Our next guest
is a comedian, actress
and the host of her very
own late night talk show.
It's amazing, you gotta check it out.
From NBC's "A Little
Late With Lilly Singh",
please welcome Lilly Singh.
(upbeat music)
It's great to see you. Where are you?
I love wherever, wherever
you're at! Where are you?
- [Lilly] So, thank you
so much for having me.
I'm so happy to see your face.
I am in my set house,
which is my fun house
where I'm shooting season two
of "A Little Late With Lilly
Singh", so not my real house-
a rented house that I won't be upset about
if the walls get dinged
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- [Kelly] You haven't been to my house,
you'd find another house,
um, so it looks great!
I love your vibe. I love well, obviously,
I love color as well, but
you're always so colorful
and so bright. Like, I
feel like I could be having
the worst day ever, and
I see you, and I smile.
You're like that person,
yeah, I love that about you.
And you did an interview
recently that caught my eye
because check this out everybody.
- [Lilly] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] That sunflower jumpsuit,
what's happening, and where do I get one?
- [Lilly] I'm gonna text
you all the details,
but I did learn that sunflowers
and clearly you have some
there are your favorite flower.
And here's the thing I'm so bummed, Kelly,
because, you know, we can't
be doing this in person,
we have to be doing this over zoom,
but that didn't stop me
from getting you flowers
that I could give you virtually.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- I will- I will just
take them home for myself,
but they're for you!
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] So it's a gift for everyone.
Well, you and I, you
and I text often about
the talk show stuff and especially,
I mean, right when both of
us started our talk shows
the world like shut down.
- [Lilly] Yep.
- [Kelly] So, I know we
both keep going, you know,
back and forth about, "Wait, what are you-
what can you do? what can you do?"
'Cause it's like the weirdest thing
to shoot a show right now.
But I love how authentic you
insist on being in your show.
It's just that you're,
is that something you've
always been like since you were a kid?
- [Lilly] Thank you! Well, this
is the best interview ever.
Keep the compliments
coming, Kelly, my God!
Honestly, it's something that I worked on.
You know, when I made
my first YouTube videos,
I was uncomfortable, and then
I learned to get to a place
to be myself and when
I started "Late Night",
I had to go through that
journey all over again.
Like, admittedly, in season one,
I thought there was moments
where I wasn't completely being myself.
Maybe I was nervous or I
felt a lot of pressure,
and, so, with season two,
I'm really prioritizing
throwing all facades out the window,
I wanna be completely authentic.
You know, me and my producers always have
little mini headbutt sessions,
because I'll be interviewing a guest
and they'll script something that's like,
"You know, I love doing this movie,"
and I'll be like, "I've
never seen that movie."
And I insist on being authentic about it,
because I don't wanna lie.
I'd rather make the time
to watch all of the things
before I interview someone
and if I don't have the time,
I'd rather be honest and say like,
"Listen, people online are
going crazy about you,"
as opposed to like, "I
loved you in this movie
and I'm such a big fan,"
because it just feels like
it doesn't sound real.
Putting on a facade and
putting on a face and lying,
it's exhausting.
It's so much more fun to
just be real and be yourself.
Yes, it's a little more scary,
but I just feel like I'm in
such a good place right now
where I'm so weird and
I show it on my show
and I have nothing to hide.
I'm just like, "This weirdo is who you get
and you're not gonna get anybody else."
- [Kelly] I think we're
all a little weird,
I think that's why people love you.
Like, we're all a little weird
and I don't think that's abnormal.
- [Lilly] Me and you,
specifically, are super weird.
- [Kelly] Yeah, we might be
at the end of the spectrum,
(Kelly laughs)
that's fine,
it's working out for us.
But wait, I wanna ask you about this,
because you've actually
been working with OLAY,
and so can you tell us
about their new campaign
and the OLAY skin promise?
- [Lilly] For sure. I actually love this,
and it's one of the many reasons
I love working with OLAY.
The OLAY skin promise is a commitment
to not retouching my
skin in advertisements.
And they're the first
mass brand skincare line
to do this in the US.
And so this has also helped
with my authenticity,
because it's like my blemishes,
my pimples don't get retouched.
It's me being proud in the skin I'm in.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love that!
And do you have a favorite OLAY products?
I'm like really into skincare,
because I have like hormonal acne, so.
- [Lilly] Oh, yeah, I do
have a favorite product.
I mean, I love a lot of their products,
but here's the deal, Kelly,
I'm gonna be real with you.
I have to leave my house
to go to set at 7:30 AM.
So, obviously, I set my
alarm for 7:15 AM and then I-
- [Kelly] We're the same.
- [Lilly] You think I'm
doing this as a joke,
but this is one hundred percent accurate.
I hit snooze once, but I
wake up at seven-twenty.
So, now I have 10 minutes
to get into my car,
and, literally, I brush my teeth.
I start with my OLAY Collagen
Peptide 24 moisturizer.
Absorbs quickly, it's
not sticky or greasy.
It hydrates my skin for 24
hours, which I super need,
and I just have firmer looking
skin and in like two weeks.
So, my skin has been popping
in season two, just saying.
- [Kelly] All right, well,
good news for everyone
in the house seats today;
you are all getting
a $50 CVS gift card, so you can all
try Lilly's favorite OLAY moisturizer,
and for you all at home, if
you spend $50 on OLAY products
at CVS or CVS.com, you'll
also get a $15 mail-in rebate.
So a deal is a deal, and it's amazing.
Thank you so much, Lilly!
I love you so much!
- [Lilly] Thank you! I love you, too.
- [Kelly] Good luck, good luck.
"A little late with Lilly Singh" is on NBC
at 1:35 AM Eastern and 12:25 AM central.
Y'all got to check the
show out; she's amazing.